what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so as a youtuber I oftentimes get
questions about what superheroes are
capable of and oftentimes these
questions are pretty basic but one thing
to also keep in mind here is that for
the most part new people are getting
into comic books all the time and so
what I might do is turn this into like a
series where I answer questions that
people have give them straightforward
answers with some explanation to it so
that people understand why things are
the way they are now recently I've been
focusing a lot of stories just because I
love doing stories and for the most part
I've explained all the characters that I
really find to be interesting or
fascinating but for the most part I
think that you know for this while these
questions or while this question may
seem a little basic for those of you
guys who have been reading comics for a
long time just keep in mind a lot of
people are coming to this stuff for the
very first time so user aya a.s the
question is Superman a speedster um the
answer to this question is no the
Superman is not a speedster on the whole
in DC Comics there's a difference
between a person who can move super fast
and a speedster is basically just a way
to differentiate and kind of create a
category of sorts speedsters are
basically members of the flash family so
the classic Wally West flash the new 52
flash Barry Allen the flash max mercury
you know Jay Garrick Jay Garrick's kind
of a weird situation originally he got
his powers by virtue of just exposure to
some chemical I don't know or what it is
that it's called but the result was that
it allowed him to move extremely fast
the problem with this was that he was
like the outlier everybody else tapped
into the Speed Force
except for Jay Garrick eventually he was
rolled in and his connection to the
Speed Force was established in order to
officially make him part of the flash
family but for the most part speedsters
are only people who can tap into the
Speed Force well that raises the
question what is the Speed Force well
originally the Speed Force was a concept
that was basically presented as part of
Mark Wade's run on the flash prior to
this the Speed Force was just something
that was essentially non-existent the
only thing that we really had when it
came to the flash was that he could just
run really really fast that's the way it
always was when it was you know back in
the 1930s and 40s Jay Garrick had been
exposed to a chemical this resulted in
him being able to run super fast fast
forward to the 1950s and 1956 when Barry
Allen was thrown onto the scene well it
was he was electrified he was hit with
lightning and doused with chemicals so
he could run really really fast and that
was it that was
only real explanation he got the stories
revolved around the question how fast
could he run and that's when we got
things like Barry Allen and you know
eobard thawne and these various
characters being able to run back and
forth through time they could just run
so fast they could move through time
itself they could vibrate so fast they
could move to other dimensions that's
really all it revolved around now when
crisis on Infinite Earths happened and
Mark Waid took over the flash title and
basically began writing the stories of
the classic Wally West the Speed Force
was introduced as a way to explain why
it is that speedsters can run so fast
the question users always had as time
began to progress people started asking
the question well it doesn't make any
sense that you know Barry would just be
splashed with chemicals struck by
lightning and suddenly be able to run
through time people wanted a little more
meat and potatoes to their explanation
on why heroes could do the things they
did and so Mark Waid basically said well
there's this extra dimensional source of
energy out there and this extra
dimensional source of energy is what
speedsters use in order to access their
super fast speed and so what would what
had basically been established here is
that Barry Allen had been struck by
lightning doused in chemicals and
instead of that just giving him the
ability to run super fast instead he was
able to tap into the Speed Force now
later on the writer Geoff Johns would
actually come back and change that and
say no it was actually Barry Allen
creating the Speed Force as he ran and
the result is that while Barry Allen
created the Speed Force he basically
created the source of his own power in
the future the Speed Force would grow
massive enough that anybody across the
multiverse could become a flash in
growing you know growing large enough it
began to permeate all throughout space
and time and so Barry Allen the flash
had simultaneously created the Speed
Force while tapping into a future
version of the Speed Force it's kind of
a weird scenario but this is the
explanation that was used to basically
say during crisis on Infinite Earths
instead of Barry Allen dying at the
hands of the anti-monitor barry allen
merged with the Speed Force that
explanation came with Final Crisis when
Barry Allen emerge from the Speed Force
after outrunning death now of course the
other half of this question is really
good age-old debate who's faster the
flash or Superman I mean honestly this
this questions kind of been beat to
death and I mean I guess we could offer
some kind of an explanation on it um
historically speaking they've raced time
and
again keep in mind Superman was like
DC's golden child right I mean no matter
what DC did at the end of the day
Superman always had to maintain the top
tier of their characters but fans who
were reading the flash also came to
realize that the flash was extremely
fast you can't have the flash titled as
the fastest man alive
and Superman be faster than the flash
that doesn't work it doesn't make any
sense
and so what DC did is they started
creating these stories where the
Superman and the flash would race
against one another now the first of
these came with Superman number 199 in
1967 and then after this it just turned
into this great big huge thing so you
had the flash number 175 in 1967 you had
world's finest 198 through 199 in 1970
you had DC Comics presents numbers 1 & 2
in 1978 the flash rebirth number 3 in
2009 Adventures of Superman number 4 63
in 1990 Action Comics number 314 in 1964
I mean you had all these different
stories that depicted these characters
racing off against one another but on
the whole it was usually always Superman
breaking even it was usually always
Superman tying the flash it really
wasn't until after we got into the post
Silver Age which is basically everything
after 1985 that it turned into this
whole situation of the flash just being
faster than Superman back in the 1950s
Superman could do everything
there was actually a story where
Superman or whether what the issue what
issue this story was but there was a
story where Superman basically outran
infinity whatever that means
I mean he just ran to the point of
infinity it's it doesn't make any sense
infinity is you know mathematical value
meant to indicate impossibility of
something ending that it basically goes
on forever I don't know how you manage
to outrun something going on forever
that doesn't make any sense but you know
nonetheless these are the explanations
that were given in terms of how fast
Superman was when it got into the
post-crisis on Infinite Earths era
suddenly it was the flash being able to
be faster than Superman now a lot of
this was because of the fact that with
classic Waldi West DC was writing
stories where they were depicting
classic Wally West as struggling with
the mantle of the flash you know that
Barry Allen held and so the goal was to
basically beef up classic Wally West
making his own character and in some
ways make him more power
in the flash Barry Allen there was a
story where he outran the universe of
course Barry himself would basically
outran death while he was in the Speed
Force but on the whole Superman's speed
is usually held to like a finite
standard right like flash value to says
that Superman is able to run at like
2,000 miles per second are able to fly
2,000 miles per second or something
along those lines it's like 7.2 million
miles per hour I think it is that's
usually what people sign it's usually
what the stories say they give an
absolute definitive standard in terms of
how fast Superman can fly and so what it
does is it gives fans the best of both
worlds the Superman when he's flying is
incredibly fast second probably only to
anybody in the flash family and even
faster than some of those guys like max
mercury or something along those lines
but it also allows the top two flashes
which is to say classic Wally West and
Barry Allen to remain as the fastest men
alive so hopefully that answers your
question is probably a little more
information than you need it but yeah I
mean Superman's not a speedster at all a
speedster is defined as a person who can
tap into the Speed Force in terms of
Superman versus the flash the Superman
is basically tied with the flash a
multitude of times as far as I'm aware
he's never beat the flash in races more
times in the Flash's beat him so the
other half is the Speed Force is
basically just this extra dimensional
source of energy that exists out there
that allows you know speedsters to gain
their powers kind of like their own
afterlife when speedsters die that's
where they'll go they'll go to the Speed
Force so anyway um if you guys enjoy
this sort of thing you know leave a
comment down below let me know what you
guys think hopefully it helps you guys
out answer some questions that you guys
might have out there and yeah so I'm
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end and I will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]